[Music]
as a private contractor
you're possessing a unique set of
[Music]
skills what's that
i went up you said it was clear i said
the front was clear
um
front back right wrong
anyway shall we
[Music]
so what we got something rather nasty
has been stolen
we have to stop that getting onto the
open market
who's the buyer greg simmons the
billionaire arms dealer
oh a lot very serious faces up here in
there you can't catch this fish with
conventional lures i'm sorry the lure
being honey francesco
the movie star rick simmons favorite
movie star and how do we get him
blackmail
who's to gear
very good carry on
the world needs you for your greatest
role yet who are you i'm your new
manager there's a sensitive and awkward
situation between you and your
sister-in-law i actually love my
sister-in-law
it's none of you you made that quite
evident when marimba rhythm started to
play i need to be nervous
no reason to be nervous
they're all the killers
you're an actor act
okay
i'm ready let's go to work will someone
pinch me please is that danny francesco
what's next for you i'm playing a
mysterious self-made billionaire
you just described me
shadow maybe do whatever i do
whatever i do do
whoever greg was buying from was amongst
you last night dear friends
i can get inside the ukrainians
i hope you take them to dinner first
before you get inside of them
sexually
your awesome fortune that is a sexy name
cover's blown we're burnt what do i do
the emoji style is going to melt
you stop daddy francesco you stopped
so you weren't seen by anyone
yes
that's yes you want seen by anyone
yes or yes you were seen by someone yes
[Music]
quick stretch little snack and here we
go
sonic i love that you want to help make
a difference
if you're being reckless don't worry
nobody's gonna get hurt
pretending to be batman blue justice
trademark pending
you're still just a kid
trust me there will come a moment when
your powers will be needed
but you don't choose that moment that
moment chooses you just got goosebumps
wait a second did you steal that from
oprah
papa's got a brand new stash
since i've been gone i've discovered the
source of ultimate power
that sounds big
it's been on my vision board for years
hope i'm not too late
i'm sorry who are you memes tales okay
this is what we're gonna do step one
light taunting step two i have no idea
[Music]
that wasn't too bad
today's forecast calls for a 100
chance of adventure
[Music]
return to sender
face it you're never going to get my
power
do i look like i need your power
where
are my manners sonic meet knuckles
[Music]
you led me straight to the lost city now
prepare to die there were just hundreds
of snakes in this temple just waiting
for us to show up what why aren't they
biting that guy this is ridiculous
delete delete
listen loretta we need you to promote
your new book on the lost city you can't
spend your life in the bathtub drinking
chardonnay with ice
ladies and gentlemen the world's sexiest
cover model
mcmahon you do know you're not dash
right dash is a character i made up yes
oh my god
oh crap
miss sage i enjoyed your book about the
lost city and i believe you're the one
who can help me find its treasure
i have to respectfully decline i'm
afraid i must insist
unchain me that's your seatbelt
loretta sage is missing i'm going to
rescue her i just want her to think of
me as more than a cover mind that's
standard dangerously
alan what are you doing here we're here
to save you i'm certified cpr served by
crossfit
this is like your book we're on the love
more and dash adventure right now i'm
gonna help you out a little bit let's go
what are you doing don't do that come on
get out of there this is not a romance
novel jungles eat people like us what is
that get it off
we're so close i could actually find the
lost city
if i don't get to this island my friend
and her cover model are going to die i
am driving oh oh oh
oh
the red sage getting you out of here why
are you so handsome my dad was a weather
man
hey oh she doesn't need saving in there
uh what are you doing in there
[Music]
we can't see it
but we're all trapped inside these
strange repeating loops
billions of people just living out their
lives
oblivious
but this is the moment for you to show
us what is real
[Music]
i remember this
[Music]
so deja vu
and yet it's obviously all wrong
maybe this isn't the story we think it
is
they taught you good
made you believe their world was all you
deserved
but some part of you knew that was a lie
some part of you remembered what was
real
it's so easy to forget how much noise
the matrix pumps into your head
something else makes the same kind of
noise
war
the most important choice in neil's life
is not his demand
it's my turn to believe in her
part of me feels like i have been
waiting my whole life for you
if you want to see trinity
saw this in a again
my dream ended here
[Music]
i still know
[Music]
hearts are kungfu
[Music]
if you listen carefully enough
the past whispers to you
we're here to see ours dumbledore
that would be my brother
the world as we know it is coming undone
renewal is pulling it apart with hate
if we're to defeat him you'll have to
trust me
[Music]
this is the team that's going to take
down the most dangerous wizard in over a
century
i'm a zoologist his indispensable
assistant
wizard descended from a very old family
a school teacher
and
a muggle
dumbledore said i give you something
jacob
are you kidding me right now
who wouldn't like our chances
after save the world are we
things are not quite what they appear
swivel but delicately
i'm swiveling out you're serving
[Music]
okay
what is this place
the room we require
[Music]
correct three points to hufflepuff
[Music]
[Applause]
can i mm-hmm
very dangerous it's very powerful i've
gotten wrong hands you know
mess you up where did you guess it
the guy for christmas
[Music]
nick you've been living at the sunset
tower for over a year they love having
me there you owe them six hundred
thousand dollars okay i'm gonna deal
with all that but i'm gonna get this
next roll
and when i do
all of that changes then i'm back not
that you went anywhere
nicholas cage oh my god i love you
he was so good in the rock what about
gone in 60 seconds have you seen croods
too no i'm 44 years old why the [ __ ]
would i see croods too i've seen face
off and con air we got another offer
what's it about you head to southern
spain and you attend a wealthy
gentleman's birthday party
i would never do that it's a million
bucks nick
[Music]
i'll take it
the guy that owns this house what's his
name bobby look if javi wants me to [ __ ]
his wife or watch me watch him [ __ ] his
wife that's a no-go you understand
there's no
[Music]
i am so happy that you're here is this
supposed to be me it's
protest
i'll give you 20 thousand
[Music]
what have you got there divine
inspiration
i'm paranoid let's just get up on the
count of three and run
they're coming grab my hand
you're heavier than you look i have a
very big head
you go i'll never forget your ass
mr cage it turns out we could have just
walked around wow yes so
[Music]
for centuries no human has had the power
to become a monster
until now
but is this safe though let's find out
[Music]
is everything okay down here hey drac
what's up oops
what's going on i used van helsing's
transforming ring
you're human drag dad
oh no i have a total dad bod
um what is going on
huh
what's up
i'm baldi
[Music]
who are those guys it's me uncle griffin
you don't recognize me i've literally
never seen you before
there is a place deep in the amazon only
there can the transformations be
reversed time to go
if we don't fix you guys dude you'll be
like this forever
being a human is the worst
mosquito
like adam
hotel transylvania transfer mania
boy that was fun
ready pg coming january 14th only on
prime video
what year are we in
1941
what day is today
[Music]
wednesday i think
very well
as briefly as you can
can you read minds
come on in and behold the mysteries of
the universe
i want to give you the world and
everything in it what are you talking
about
we got a little mind reading show
there's a woman abigail oh god
me teach you
everybody has some shadow from their
past
oh you're trouble ain't you that just
met me what if i told you i'd get my
hands on a two-person neck course
what is the object being held a pocket
watch
am i correct
master stanton can you comment
what's inside the bag
a small pistol
you're not as hard to read as you think
you run a racket same as me
if you help me we can make quite a big
dent in this town
you barely know me oh i know
you're no good
and i know that good
neither am i
this is not a carnival trick
if your foot slips to be both full
[Music]
we've had our share of snake charmers in
the past we deal with them
what did you do
sometimes you don't see the lie until
you cross it
he looked four people's down
they for themselves
i'm supposed to meet a man here
to take me to the compound
came from the west right
here it's getting pretty bad out that
way now
folks turning on each other
so why the compound
he's a strange place to be heading
once in a lifetime opportunity
what is it come here
look at this
that's gold
we just bought a pile of gold
one of us will have to get the excavator
to get it out
i think i'll stay with the gold
you gotta watch your water
stay out of the sun
ain't no joke out here
how much longer go as fast as i can
so you're here on your own
you need to leave
out here
you start to get real strange
where are you
i found it
it's
i can mine it
[Music]
[Music]
you got a minute oh
how did you get
how have you been
it's a long story
is this the room you grew up in uh it is
but uh my my dorm room is very adult
right no of course
hey are these your drawings what no no
good
i missed you too okay
so what are you doing here i mean i
i thought i'd
never see you again
want to get out of here
[Music]
i'm
grounded
bummer
is spider-man grounded
um
i mean
[Music]
oh
kingsman world's finest tailor
but now we're going into the spy
business
very clever based on true events
this will not be a war of heroes
[Music]
meet history's most evil legends
[Music]
weakness throwing arm
strength
started world war one
the super spy
mata hari strength
screen presence
weakness
scarves do you forget your manners
guilty as charged
have a crazed monkey
respiratory strength
and weaknesses
[Music]
you'll have to see it for yourself
it's good now yes
on december 22nd our enemies think we
are gentlemen
it's time to remind them
what the kingsmen are
[Music]
nobility is born
in blood
[Music]
boys are always so messy
the king's man only in theaters december
22nd
[Music]
sid it's happening three attacks so far
whatever his link is to our past it ends
here
i've seen this movie before not this
[Music]
are you sure about this sir no major i'm
not
this son of a [ __ ] is our only hope
he's what we like to call a problem
inmate why is that he doesn't play well
with others
[Applause]
we need you mcgruber why me you were
specifically requested
mac i'm not going to sugarcoat it it's a
suicide mission
who let the dog out
my country has invited me to die for it
and i are svp gas queen
uncle sam tells you to jump and you go
get your jumping ships classic mcgregor
hello magruber
this isn't just any mission for me this
is personal he murdered my mother
thank you soldier you're gonna get us
all killed
millions of people are gonna die we're
talking about a world enter here i think
it's time to call the calvary we are the
[ __ ] cavalry
time to go make some widows get shot
smell you later vic that mean that with
every fiber of my
will smell you later
mcgrover
i think it might be time for a little r
and r oh yes i could use some rest and
relaxation no
the other r
ramming and [ __ ]
[Music]
where am i going to a lavish and
glimmering hell
[Music]
you're something they can never be
an individual
this place is so beautiful
[Music]
[Applause]
creature in the water you should not be
swimming in there
she called me
she's certainly not of this world nor am
i
the creature will be killed placing the
life force into our hands this is murder
she is your pet she's all but human
the mermaid must escape the king
we're the only ones who can
[Music]
believe in stop
[Applause]
hey you get over here
oh i know what it is you're afraid
because i'm the big bad wolf the villain
of every story
and this is the crew mr angela mr shark
mr piranha mr snake everyone copy copy
copy
we're the bad guys it's crime time baby
shark we need a distraction to improvise
fine please be subtle
i'm having a baby
is there a doctor or perhaps several
security guards that could leave that
post and help me
we were never given a chance to be
anything more than criminals but these
are the cars we've been dealt so we
might as well play them
here let me help you
are you okay ma'am thank you dear you're
such a good boy wait what i'm a bad guy
all good brother oh good yeah yeah
you ever wonder what it'd be like if the
world wasn't scared of us never gonna
happen guys we're gonna go good
did you get hit on the head he villains
have an image problem you need a
makeover
so
well there goes our street cred
well i'm tired of being an outcast maybe
i don't want to be a what a bad guy
you're going to have to choose between
your friends or the good life they're
the only friends i have ever had you
have a chance to write your own story
what have you got salute i don't know my
dignity
yeah well that ship has already sailed
that is an animal testing that with
helpless guinea pigs i'll rescue them
you've never volunteered for anything
oh
come on snake open up relax these doors
are complicated
are you kidding me we're supposed to
save them not eat them well i'd say
they've gone to a better place
guys
[Music]
[Music]
mrs wang are you with us
i am paying
attention now you may only see a pile of
proceeds but i see a story
i can see where this story is going
it does not look
good
what's happening
i'm not your husband i'm one of the
first ones from another universe i'm
here because we need your help
very busy today so time to help you
across the multiverse
their emotions
even the skills
there's a great evil spreading about the
many verses
and you
may be your only chance of stopping it
don't make me find you i am really good
i don't believe you
he's waiting in the wings the universe
he speaks of senseless things is so much
bigger
than you realize
of all the places i could be
i just wanted to share with you
remember our mission concerning the fate
of every single world of our infinite
there multiverse no way i am the eveline
you are looking for
every rejection
every disappointment
has led you here
to this
moment
don't let anything distract you from it
[Music]
this
box edgar
[Music]
it's not what you think it is
it was built to contain something
not of this world
by opening the box i have released it
release what
a demon
a demon must continue to get what he
wants
it has the power to rip me off my
illness
[Music]
i'm not sure i can do this
six sacrifices
and i
will live
[Music]
you won't let me down while you edgar
we're gonna finish this
together
[Music]
[Music]
where's
uh
[Music]
me
[Music]
[Music]
huh
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
wow
foreign